a couple of days ago on this show
i was discussing
how terrible dr fauci is and i just sort
of off the top of my head said that i
wanted every candidate for federal
office
to sign a pledge i wanted them to sign
the michael knowles public health
protection pledge and that pledge would
have to include two things one
if you are elected to congress or the
senate you will
vote to subpoena dr fauci and
investigate him and then using the power
of the purse in congress you will zero
out his salary so you can't fire him if
you're in congress but you can get rid
of his salary
very simple just two things i pledge
that i will do this mentioned it on the
show we moved on with the rest of the
show
then yesterday i see a message from a
congressional candidate beau hines beau
hines is running for congress in north
carolina and
he said michael i heard the show
we had our staff draft up the pledge i
am honor honored and proud to be the
first candidate to sign this pledge i
said bo that's really funny he posted it
to social media
all of a sudden a ton of different
congressional candidates senate
candidates candidates all over the
country
start posting their
photos
of the pledge and they're signing it
here it is i've got the pledge right
here in my hands
it's very simple
michael knowles federal public health
protection pledge i
so and so pledge to the taxpayers of the
state or commonwealth of whatever the
place is and to the american people that
i will one
vote to subpoena dr anthony fauci in
order to investigate any corrupt
activities to which he may be party
regarding the covid pandemic as well as
the numerous and demonstrable lies that
he has told to the u.s congress and the
american people regarding the virus its
origin and the efficacy of public health
measures to fight it and two
i will sponsor and vote for legislation
that reduces the salary of the director
of the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases niaid and chief
medical advisor to the president of the
united states dr anthony fauci to zero
dollars and zero cents
candidate signs here witness signs here
very simple
okay a ton of candidates have already
signed this pledge i need you i need
your help
to get every other
congressional candidate senate candidate
incumbent sitting politician at the
federal level to sign this pledge i want
you to tag your congressman your center
i want you to tweet this at them i want
you i want them on the record i want
this anthony fauci gone i want him cast
out of public life i don't want him to
have any more political power in this
country i will not vote for a candidate
at the federal level in 2022 who does
not sign this pledge and you should not
either i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from steve robson
who says
what most protects people from covid19
turning off the tv that is true that is
probably the best protection you're
going to get from the truly negative
side effects of covid19 which have
nothing to do with the virus itself
in virtually all cases and have almost
everything to do
with the policies that that power-hungry
politicians have put in place ostensibly
to fight the virus
there's been a ton of downsides the last
couple of years
it just seems like downside after
downside after downside so when you want
to get upside i'd really recommend you
go check out
get upside gas prices are through the
roof as you very well know
well i've got a little gift for you that
would be get upside you download the
free get upside app and you can get 25
cents cash back per gallon
every time you fill up your car well
that's not quite true
there's a little caveat here
if you use promo code knowles with the
free getupside app
you can actually get 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first
fill up
people who drive a lot are saving
two to three hundred dollars per year
they're getting it in cash back there's
no catch only cash only cash back goes
to your bank account goes to paypal if
you prefer or goes to an amazon gift
card or some other shop if you like it's
very simple
you download the free get upside app use
promo code knowles to get 25 cents per
gallon or more cash back on your first
tank
that is code knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
do not let this very difficult economy
and all these gas prices get you down
too much get that cash back get upside
code nulls
why do we need to get rid of dr fauci
because almost every single thing he has
said is wrong
kind of by definition on on every issue
at least he has said the wrong thing and
one of the ways that i know this is
because he's held both sides of
virtually every issue he said we
shouldn't have lockdowns and he said we
should have lockdowns he said we
shouldn't have masks then he said we
should have masks he said
we don't need to double mask he said we
do need to double mask he said this that
and the other thing
the lockdowns in particular
have been killers they've been killers
deaths of despair are through the roof
especially drug overdoses i think they
jumped something like 30
in one year why because people were kept
away from their support networks they
were kept away from
what was considered to be elective
medical help
various tests screenings counseling
they were locked up in their rooms and
they had very little to do what are you
going to do in that world
there are lots of other negative effects
of the lockdowns these poor kids you
know the kids who aren't allowed to see
their friends who aren't allowed to
develop normally you're just locked up
you had teen anxiety you had all sorts
of
teenage problems going through the roof
well
turns out
that the lockdowns
very likely
were completely pointless from a medical
perspective there's a study out of johns
hopkins
that says here it is
studies and applied economics something
like a 70-page study here's the first
part of it studies in applied economics
a literature review and meta-analysis of
the effects of lockdowns on kovid19
mortality
says the lockdowns were pointless
quote while this meta-analysis concludes
that lockdowns have had little to no
public health effects they have imposed
enormous economic and social costs where
they have been adopted in consequence
lockdown policies are ill-founded
goes on the evidence fails to confirm
that lockdowns have a significant effect
in reducing covet-19 mortality the
effect is little to none
the use of lockdowns is a unique feature
of the covet 19 pandemic lockdowns have
not been used to such a large extent
during any of the pandemics in the past
century however lockdowns during the
initial phase of the coveted 19 pandemic
have had devastating effects they have
contributed to reducing economic
activity raising unemployment reducing
schooling causing political unrest
contributing to domestic violence and
undermining liberal democracy these
costs to society must be compared to the
benefits of lockdowns which our
meta-analysis has shown are marginal at
best such a standard benefit cost
calculation leads to a strong conclusion
lockdowns should be rejected out of hand
as a pandemic policy instrument
what the left has been telling us
from
almost day one certainly since they
started to endorse these lockdowns
is look it's unpleasant no one wants to
do it it's tough it's hard but you need
to do it to flatten the curve and slow
the spread and save your fellow man
it's patriotic it's patriotic they told
us to lock down yes it's hard but we're
sacrificing
we're sacrificing for the greater good
except we're not we were sacrificing for
the bad we were sacrificing for the
greater bad
because according to this study
this meta-analysis of many other studies
from johns hopkins the lockdowns had
little to no
public health benefit
or really effect at all
and lots of devastating consequences
from society by many other
metrics
yeah of course
of course we knew that we knew this is
nothing new i'm not telling i am very
few people who listen to this show did
not already know that the lockdowns were
medically pointless
maybe some maybe some of the wonderful
democrats and moderates and independents
who listened to this show were on the
fence but i wouldn't estimate most
people who listen to this show already
knew the lockdowns were pointless but
you weren't allowed to say that
you weren't allowed to say that you
could be censored you you could be
contradicting the the
expert opinion of the geniuses at the
cdc and dr fauci and joe biden you know
all those experts and geniuses you could
be
kicked off of social media for saying
that
if you pointed out that the lockdowns
were politically very useful for the
people in power medically not very
useful at all
so the question now is not ha ha
how right were we oh how good do we feel
that we were right the question is what
are we being censored
for now that is going to be proven
that where it will be proven that we are
correct in six to nine months we
frequently say now at this point the
difference between
the truth and a conspiracy theory is
about six to nine months
the conspiracy theories seem to get
proven true well we won't even have to
wait that long here's one here's one
thing that we're not allowed to say now
where i maybe i'll be censored if i say
this and if i am we'll put a sensor bar
over me on youtube or something
ivermectin
probably
has some antiviral effect when it comes
to covid19
i'm willing to say that i know i'm i'm
violating all the rules of dr fauci
but i bet
that iver mektin called a wonder drug by
all the expert geniuses just five or six
years ago
a wonderful antiviral probably has some
kind of antiviral effect
on
covid19 ivermectin is not horse paste or
horse dewormer any more than aspirin is
a hoarse drug ivermectin is a human drug
can be used for animals too but it's a
human drug and i bet
that it has even though you're not
allowed to say i bet that it's gonna
have some antibiotic oh actually i don't
need to wait that long a japanese
company
has just come out it's a japanese
pharmaceuticals company kawa
has been doing research on ivermectin
and they have found an anti-viral effect
quote this is this is from from reuters
so reuters this is not some far right
wing outlet this is from reuters the
company which has been working with
tokyo's kita sato university on testing
the drug as a potential uh treatment for
covet 19 did not provide further details
but they did find an anti-viral
effect
here's what the washington post said
this is some months ago how those
ivermectin conspiracy theories convinced
people to buy horse dewormer hahaha
remember cnn mocked joe rogan joe
rogan's eating horse drugs ha
a bunch of media figures suggested that
ivermectin overdoses were killing people
over and and sending them to oklahoma
hospitals that was completely made up
there was just a 100 fake news story as
the as the daily wire debunked the fda
even said it they said quote you are not
a horse you are not a cow serious y'all
seriously y'all stop it
we're the geniuses we're the experts
stop that ivermectin has no there's a
zero percent chance that has any
antiviral effect oh whoopsie daisy
just one japanese pharmaceutical company
that that has the hutzpah to look into
it says oh yeah it looks like
looks like it might have antiviral
properties what are we told now
is impossible what are we censored for
saying now that's going to be proven
true in six months
i don't know you're going to hear it on
this podcast whenever it is proven true
another great podcast to listen to
jordan harbinger have you still not
checked out the jordan harbinger show
this is a top shelf podcast named best
of apple in 2018 jordan dives into the
minds of fascinating people from
athletes to authors to scientists to
mobsters to spies
harbinger has a talent for getting his
guests to share never heard before
stories
and thought-provoking insights without
fail he pulls out tactical bits of
wisdom in each episode all with the
noble intent to make you more informed
make you a more critical thinker better
able to operate in today's world he's
got a strangely relatable weekly segment
called feedback friday where jordan
covers advice on everything from psycho
family situations to relationships to
networking you can't go wrong by adding
the jordan harbinger show to your
rotation it's a great show there's never
a dull show search for the jordan
harbinger show that is h-a-r-b as in boy
i-n as in nancy g-e-r as in really go
check it out on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcasts
that is the jordan harbinger show
do you know how i knew
that
the lockdowns were going to be proven to
be medically pointless do you know how i
knew that the cloth masks were going to
be proven to be medically pointless as
now all of the health experts admit as
the cdc admits as the cnn medical
analyst admits do you know how i knew
that
there were going to be side effects at
least in some cases and some number of
cases from the vaccines do you have do
you know how i knew all of those things
were eventually going to be proven true
as they have been proven true
because of the pushback
because they were perfectly reasonable
questions
that had been voiced by plenty of very
well-respected sorts of people including
dr fauci remember dr fauci made fun of
the masks and said they were stupid
and then all of a sudden you weren't
allowed to say it and if you did say it
you were a murderer and you were a
danger and you had to be censored and
you had to be ostracized
the minute that happened
i knew it was very likely going to be
proven true
dr fauci
dr fauci where's my pledge don't forget
the pledge get your candidates to sign
the pledge
the public health protection pledge to
fire dr fauci
why why on the just this question of
ivermectin which just this japanese
pharmaceuticals company has been
researching has found that it's got some
antiviral properties okay
why would would
the government suppress the use of
certain drugs such as let's say
ivermectin but others too
and promote
the vaccines and promote really only one
drug remdezavir
well let's think about it let's take
let's take off our scientist hats for a
second because we're talking about a
political question now let's put on our
politician hats don't forget dr fauci he
plays a scientist on tv but he is
primarily a politician he gets his
paycheck from the federal government he
answers to political pressures
he's one of the most powerful
politicians in america
why would the government discourage the
use of certain therapeutics
there's two reasons i can see
money and power
when you're talking about politics
usually it's going to boil down to those
two things money
and power
dr fauci has always been a big promoter
of vaccines
i'm not even saying it comes from a
place of dishonesty he just believes
that vaccines are the best way to
improve the public health
this was true during aids this was true
during the 2000s during some of the the
bioterrorism scares that is true today
he's all about vaccines first so if
you're promoting the vaccines and the
widespread adoption of vaccines it would
stand to reason that you might want to
discourage the use of therapeutics
because if there's a very simple
therapeutic to deal with
some kind of epidemic then people are
going to be discouraged from getting the
vaccine
why would i take some experimental
vaccine
or some experimental drug that even
doesn't have all the properties of a
vaccine when i could just get the virus
if the virus isn't that bad i can just
take a therapeutic and i'll most likely
be fine
so you've got to suppress the use of
long-standing well-known therapeutics
but then okay what about in this case
the public health establishment is
really pushing one therapeutic
above all and almost exclusively that
would be rem deserver
rem deserver is this drug it's the one
drug that the federal government seems
to be really pushing
why might they be pushing it
i guess it could be because in their
medical opinion and their totally
unbiased medical opinion rem deserves by
far the best drug except there have been
a lot of articles in mainstream outlets
including abc nbc forbes that have
suggested that rem desevere doesn't
really work that well
might it have something to do with the
fact that some of these older
long-standing treatments that we've all
heard about cost i don't know 10 bucks a
shot
and remdezavir costs 3 500 per treatment
rem deserve produced by gilead which
spent almost two and a half million
dollars lobbying the federal government
in the first quarter of 2020.
who knows how much since then
might it have some i'm not i'm not even
suggesting some massive conspiracy where
people are hiding out in bunkers and
smoke-filled rooms cooking up ways to
take over the world
i'm just suggesting basic politics
power
and money
those are those are very important
things
and if you're a politician
and you are offered
a way to increase your or maintain your
power
and to
[Music]
be influenced by some amount of money
that's going to have an effect that
almost always does have an effect
maybe that has something to do with it
are you even allowed to ask that are we
even allowed
to ask about money
and influence in politics anymore or is
that that's a conspiracy theory too
because the left was
babbling on about that for many many
years many many decades but now that
they're the ones who are trying to
maintain their influence and their money
all of a sudden we're not allowed to
talk about it okay makes sense right
speaking of really bad democrat policies
and actually the public health as well
there is a crime epidemic through this
country the crime epidemic which if it
hit gets a hold of you is going to be a
whole lot deadlier than any kind of
virus bullets tend to be a lot deadlier
than most viruses
you've got you've got this crime
spreading all around the country
gensake was just asked about this
because the democrats are widely
perceived to be soft on crime
she laughs off the answer
if you look at fox on a daily basis i
mean do you remember the four boxes that
you had that we had on all the tvs right
which is on my tv right now so right now
just to give you a sense so cnn pentagon
as many as 8 500 u.s troops on
heightened alert okay true same on msnbc
cnbc is doing their own thing about the
market and then on fox is janine pirro
talking about soft on crime consequences
i mean what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe on some
uh coverage what's scary about it is a
lot of people watch that it's like what
does that even mean soft on crime what
do you what does that even mean does it
mean that um
violent crime is up 23 nationally
i guess that's what it could mean does
it mean that
homicides are up 58 percent in atlanta
democrat-run city
or that uh homicides are up 533
in portland democrat run city
or that homicides are up
37 percent philadelphia democrat run
city
or that shootings are up 54
in new york is that a just want to check
oh it's a democrat-run city or does that
mean that shootings are up
18
and democrat run chicago the shootings
were already so high in chicago it's
hard for them to go any higher but they
managed to go a little bit higher 18 or
that they're up 51 in los angeles a
democrat run city maybe that's what it
means what does that even mean soft on
crime
jen saki probably doesn't know what it
means
gen saki probably doesn't know what it
means because she doesn't live in bad
neighborhoods
she lives i imagine in a pretty nice
neighborhood
i bet
everyone who works for the biden
administration
lives in a pretty nice neighborhood
they never have to deal with the
consequences of their policies and what
are those policies abolish the police
defund the police install
soft prosecutors who refuse who simply
refuse to prosecute violent criminals
who let them out of jail when they're in
jail and don't send them to jail in the
first place when they have the
opportunity
direct police these aren't my words
abolish the police is not my phrase
defund the police is not my phrase
abolish prisons is not my phrase
over-incarceration is not my that's
these are democrat phrases democrat
campaigns and policies
that have led to a massive crime surge
that jens hockey and joe biden and none
of these people are ever going to deal
with because they live in really nice
neighborhoods
and so they're focused on things that
really matter to them like ukraine which
no one not one person in actual america
who isn't working for the liberal
establishment in the media in the elite
echelons of government not one other
person cares about ukraine do we need to
make sure that we defend certain allies
and oppose certain threats at the level
of geopolitics yeah sure okay fine i'm
not disputing that
but people care much much more about
their own neighborhoods in new york and
chicago and los angeles than they care
about freaking kiev
much much more
and this glib dismissal of people's
concerns is the reason why the democrats
approval ratings are in the gutter right
now why joe biden is at 30 percent
and by the way he's basically the most
popular person in his administration
everyone in the administration is in the
30s right now
and the policies are continuing
what does what does soft end crime look
like here's one story
this is from dhs department of homeland
security
has decided not to deport
a man named harry berto fuerte padilla
riberto fuerte padilla is an illegal
alien
uh he was not deported
for the long period of time that he
lived in america he got drunk drove a
car and killed a teenager in texas an
american teenager in texas
killed her oh and then he fled the scene
so it was a hit and run he fled the
scene he was arrested
they were going to deport him finally
too late apparently but they were going
to deport him and then dhs decided nope
we're not going to deport him we're not
even going to deport a drunk driving
illegal alien who killed a teenager
that's what soft on crime means
gen saki
really really
frustrating stuff because when you are
relying on the people that we've we've
traditionally trusted
to help you out help you fix up things
in your community you're going to be
disappointed so you got to fix things
yourself when you want to go fix things
yourself when you want to get auto parts
yourself you really should go check out
rock auto a lot of people make new
year's resolutions i'm going to work out
i'm gonna eat less i'm gonna drink less
i'm gonna okay right whatever here's one
for you
spend less time at the brick and mortar
auto parts store well you can just go to
rockauto.com they've got an incredibly
easy to navigate catalog
they've got reliably low prices it's not
gimmicks it's not 20 off on tuesday at
11 a.m it's reliably low
it's a family-owned business they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years they've got the same prices
for pros and do-it-yourselfers and
you're just going to save a lot of money
you're going to save a lot of money
you can save 50
on an auto part but you're also going to
save a lot of time which is money
because you're not going to have to get
in the car and drive to the place and
wait in line and then the guy goes in
the back he pepper you know he first
peps you with questions he goes in the
back they don't have the part he tells
you you gotta wait you gotta drive back
you gotta wait two weeks don't do it
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and then write knowles
k-n-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
the final part of candace owens's
exclusive interview with dr robert
malone aired last night and is now
streaming only at the daily wire
dailywire.com
get ready for part two it's airing
tonight at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
take a look at the preview
in order to evaluate any vaccine you
want to hear both sides of an argument
all media and information that we are
currently encountering is manipulated i
want to jump in and talk about when your
interview with joe rogan started going
viral not only was google triggered a
whole range of of legacy media work
triggered it's an entire ecosystem of
illegality and corruption you should be
and you are appropriately outraged about
this you can judge the value of society
by how it treats its children our
treatment of our children has been
atrocious this is the red line right
this is the line what is it that drives
you to keep going toward truth i've been
given the gift that i might be able to
make a positive impact how can i walk
away from it
[Music]
you can watch both parts of this
interview exclusively at dailywire.com
remember part two is premiering tonight
9 pm eastern 8 pm central if you do not
already have a daily wire membership
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
right now use code science s-c-i-e-n-c-e
science follow it you get 25 off we'll
be right back with a lot more
the department of homeland security is
refusing to deport a drunk driving
illegal alien who killed a texas teen
furthermore
u.s customs us immigration and customs
enforcement ice
has told
texas that it's cancelling more
deportation requests these are detainers
on other illegal immigrants
including some people who pled guilty to
felony charges of evading arrest or had
convictions not even just arrests
convictions for drunk driving
drug possession or domestic assault
injuring a family member they're not
going to deport even those people
they're just going to let them stay
where is this coming from
where is this is this
coming from the the ice agents
they're the ones who say we don't want
to deport them i doubt it
usually the rank and file
guys are
interested in doing their jobs it's
usually not their fault when their jobs
are not being done it's usually their
boss's faults the political's faults
so is it alejandra mayorkas fault the
secretary of homeland security
i actually don't think it's his fault
i don't particularly care for that guy
but he was just caught on a hidden
microphone
just just the other day
complaining about this he said the
border situation is the worst it has
been in at least 20 years if not ever
which looks really bad for him i suspect
mayorkas probably wants to enforce the
law at least a little bit more
i think this is coming from biden well i
don't think anything's coming from biden
i don't think biden knows what day it is
but i think that this is coming from
the white house i think this is coming
from
the radical
leftist democrats who are surrounding
the president and running the white
house
and i think the order is coming from on
high
to dhs to ice
don't deport these people
and it's having really devastating
political effects
for non-radical leftists it's really
ginning up the base
but
the base is not going to win them
elections
really really bad stuff
and and mayorkas looks absolutely
terrible
now
the
this guy harry berto fuerte padilla
he would be an example
of a very bad hispanic person in america
turning to a very good hispanic person
in america
of which there are many
i have to give a huge amount of credit
to attorney general jason miares
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly he
is the new attorney general in virginia
he was brought in with the yunkan
administration
this guy is absolutely crushing it he's
been in office for what five minutes now
already
already three virginia universities big
universities
are choosing to end their vaccine
mandate
why
why because they're afraid of big bag
jason yeah actually that's why
because the attorney general sent out a
legal opinion
just sent it out to all of his
colleagues all of his constituents he
said it is my opinion quote
that absent scientific authority
conferred by the general assembly public
institutions of higher education in
virginia may not require vaccination
against covid19 as a general condition
of students enrollment or in-person
attendance
that's my opinion guys
so students
if you if you
decide to sue if you decide to make this
illegal matter just letting you know
here that the attorney general is on
your side and not on the side of the
administrators and the leftists and dr
fauci
and so what happens the universities say
okay
we give up
this is a great example
of culture being downstream of politics
i don't want to make fun of breitbart's
motto too much because the point that he
was making is true enough
you know politics is downstream of
culture the idea that the movies affect
the way that our society works and
artwork and in civil institutions yeah
sure of course that's obviously true
that's not the whole story folks
that's not an excuse for cowardly
republican politicians not to govern not
to do their job not to wield the
political power that we the people give
them
you politicians you still have to do
your job one of your jobs by the way
sign the public health protection pledge
that you will investigate dr fauci and
get rid of his salary very important for
all
candidates for congress or the senate
this year to do that
but
but
we need to recognize that at every level
of the government
people can wield political power and
that political power is going to have
cultural effects when this guy this
attorney general says here's what the
law says now here's my interpretation of
the law and i'm willing to take this to
court and i'm going to fight very hard
for my interpretation of the law
then the cultural institutions like the
universities which are not purely
private sector by the way right they get
public funding but they're also kind of
in the private sphere
like like most things in our society
google it's not a not just a private
company it's not just the government
it's kind of a little bit both it's a
little bit blurry politics and culture
get blurry sometimes
public and private get blurry sometimes
they are going to
answer to what the the politics what the
government has said
very important
good news out of universities in
virginia
there's some bad news
out of universities in washington dc
one university in particular
georgetown law school
there's a big dust up at georgetown law
school
the dust up is this ilia shapiro who is
a libertarian lecturer at the georgetown
law school and he's the head of the
center for the constitution ilia shapiro
said that biden is is doing the wrong
thing by limiting his selection for the
supreme court to a black woman
by excluding effectively 94 percent of
of americans from consideration
elias shapiro suggested that an an
indian woman
who is a judge b
biden's pick
he said that she is the best candidate
and every other candidate would be a
lesser candidate
and the way he phrased it i guess was a
little inaudible but he said it should
be this woman but joe biden because he's
playing this identity politics thing is
going to instead nominate a lesser
nominee who is a black woman
and this has been
i think willfully misconstrued by
leftists to sound as though elia shapiro
is saying that black women as a category
are lesser than some other group which
obviously is nobody it's just literally
not what he's saying and it's quite
clearly in context not not the point
that he's making so what happens in this
case
students are disagreeing with a
professor
whether because they've misunderstood
what he's saying
because these students are
they're not the creme de la creme as we
will come to see
or because
they
are willfully trying to misunderstand
what he's saying so that they can get
rid of him what what do you do
in a good flourishing society you would
just argue your point
calmly rationally say that this
professor is wrong and he he should face
x y and z consequences but because we're
not living in a reasonable time right
now the students are instead
huffing and puffing and throwing a
temper tantrum and dragging the dean of
the law school into a struggle session
where they say they need a place to cry
a place to cry seriously georgetown law
students this is a good law school and
these students are saying we you we
don't have enough places to cry on
campus
and and and the craziest part about the
whole story is
the dean is indulging them
it's really hard to walk out carrie
it is really really hard to walk out of
class or leaving in tears
and you should always have a place on
campus where you can go and feel like
you're not then also under people's eyes
and observation maybe you don't want to
answer a question of what's going on or
what's wrong
and if you're finding that you're not
getting the person you want to talk to
or not getting a space that you need
reach out to me any time anytime
so we will find your space and we will
find human rights
these students do not need places to cry
these students
need
to shut up
get themselves together
and then behave like adults behave like
like future lawyers there is no crying
in the law there's no crying in baseball
there's no crying in the law
they do need comfort these students but
they don't need a a box of tissues for
comfort they need comfort like we see on
the bio tapestry bio tapestry very
famous work of western art where there
is an image of of a bishop
holding a club swinging the club at his
soldiers and it says here bishop odo
wielding a club comforts the boys i'm
not saying we literally need to start
clubbing students who cry a lot but i
but i am saying that we need comfort in
that
sense meaning to give strength to
toughen them up saying get back in the
fight fellas
no way sorry you can't behave like a
six-year-old if you want to be a a
lawyer if you if you want to be at a
prestigious law school if these students
can't hear an opinion that they disagree
with without bursting into tears they
should be expelled because they're not
they're not up to snuff they're not
competent
they're not educated and they might
maybe they're intelligent enough maybe
not they're certainly not educated
enough to be in law school and so they
need to leave they need to go away from
law school for a little while and grow
up and and then maybe they can be at the
level where they can attend a
prestigious law school but right now
they're not there if they're bursting
into tears because some libertarian
makes a perfectly fine point
they're not there
this the crazy part
is not even the students i feel bad for
these students they're not well prepared
they're not well educated they shouldn't
be at georgetown law school
it's the administrators that i really
blame at one point one of these students
you gotta you gotta almost give her
credit
she
brought up out of nowhere she said that
there is uh people talk about
reparations for black people in america
and so she wants reparations to begin
right now by having the dean bring her
some snacks
and the dean
acquiesces
coming back to the reparation things
because like this is this is great but
we have to do so much work to catch up
for all this stuff that we miss all i'm
saying is i don't know if it's a couple
dinners or lunches or something
but
that would help us because we like we
can't i can't go home for lunch now
because i need to study i have to i have
to make up for this class that i lost so
it's little things like that it doesn't
have to be something that takes a year
to figure out it's like to we know our
black students or whatever group is
hurting and we're going to give them
things today whether it's snacks whether
it's counseling whether it's whatever
but the part of that trust is to see an
immediate reaction to what we are saying
but who will be great
we have food on the way
i'm good
it's that's the most pathetic part at
the end
i hope this girl is half joking i think
she's half joking but she's half not
joking too she's saying we need snacks i
missed class and i got to make up that
class now because i cried because i
couldn't stand it i wasn't able to make
it through class because i'm obviously
not prepared for this law school
and so i had to go cry
and so i need i need snacks and i need
you to bring me some dinner and i need
you to bring us dinner
on the basis of our race the white kids
don't need dinner
the asian kids don't need dinner but the
black kids need dinner she's saying we
don't we're not capable of getting our
own dinner and our own snacks i don't
think that's true i bet that girl can
probably get her own snacks in fact i
bet that girl doesn't even really need
to cry
i bet she is wielding vulnerability as a
mask for her own viciousness
and her own desire to to
beat her political opponents into
submission that's what i think this is
really i don't think i think these are
crocodile tears
of very vicious people
who have been very badly educated
but and i bet she can get her own snacks
and i bet she can get her own dinner she
seems perfectly capable she's capable of
bringing the dean of the law school to
his knees i think she can probably go
get a bag of potato chips
the craziest part about it
is that the dean of the law school says
of course snacks are already on the way
we're already doing it we already agree
with you
we already agree with your
deeply offensive
premises and we've already done it
the issue is not that these students are
entitled
and uneducated
and radical
these students might be particularly all
three of those things
but students
since the dawn of time
have been entitled
uneducated
and radical
that has been true
in not just in washington dc but around
the world this is true of every race of
every sex of every
type of person
some more some less but that's always
true
the issue is that the administrators are
indulging it it used to be the case that
when students would do stupid things the
administrators would smack them on the
wrist and say don't do that
none of that it used to be that when
students would do stupid things they
would be punished for it
now they are rewarded for it and the
only person who is going to be punished
in this situation
is the
is the professor elia shapiro who made a
perfectly innocuous point an obvious
point frankly
even if it was inartfully said
no one re i don't think anyone
really thinks that this guy hates black
women or something like that
he's making a point he's he's actually
making the point that we shouldn't
discriminate against people on the basis
of their race and sex
and they're saying well because you
won't discriminate against people on the
basis of their race and sex you are a
racist and a sexist
and one student
asked the most radical question of all
at this struggle session
and it's
the conservatives are
pouncing
to use the the verb that is always used
in the new york times and the washington
post conservatives are pouncing on this
comment
but it's actually a good question
this guy ilia shapiro directs the center
for the constitution he's an originalist
interpreter of the constitution and the
student asks why do we need a center for
the constitution at all
student at george georgetown law school
asked the dean trinor
in in the wake of this ilia shapiro
non-traversing
uh this this professor who has an
originalist view it says why does the
center exist at all now don't forget the
struggle session we're talking about
here was supposedly all just about how
a professor made a racist comment the
professor didn't make a racist comment
it was all supposed to be just about
race right and working through that but
but it's really not about race and it's
really not about students being offended
by a professor's views of race and sex
which are views he doesn't even hold
this is about something much deeper this
is about kicking conservatives off
campus
nothing to do with race nothing to do
with sex everything to do with politics
and philosophy
finally this
this this one
uh
this one student asks the dean
why does this center for the
constitution exist at all so elias
shapiro he does i misspoke he doesn't
direct the center but he's affiliated
with these views right originalism and
with this center
so the the director of the center randy
barnett
also holds the same views and the
student says why was it created
because so far it seems like it has done
more harm than good you can do as much
diversity training as you want with
staff but i feel like that center has a
certain ideology
so i really want you to defend why we
really need it beyond like you know free
speech and beyond diversity opinion
i really want us to think critically
about why we still need it
this is a great question this is a great
question
i'm glad she asked i don't think it's a
stupid question
why do we need it beyond you know free
speech or diversity of opinion
right this obviously this student has no
respect for free speech whether in the
absolute or in
in the actual american tradition
obviously has no respect for diversity
of opinion
but why do we need it why do we need
an originalism
institute at georgetown law
what what i think most conservatives
would say is because we need diversity
of opinion on campus
because we need free speech on campus
right they would they would defend it in
the abstract
but we don't need every single view on
every single subject represented on
campus
i don't think that conservatives would
necessarily maybe they would these days
unfortunately but i don't think we need
a satanist institute on campus do we
i don't think we need a pedophilia
institute on campus do we
i don't think we need a torture little
puppies institute on campus do well if
dr fauci had his way we probably would
have a torture puppies institute another
reason to sign the pledge the public
health protection pledge that you will
investigate and get rid of dr vouch's
salary make sure you get all of your
candidates to assign that
but we don't need those things
there is no
even semi-plausible reading of academic
freedom that says that we need
pedophilia and satanism and torturing
little puppies
on campus
right
certain things can be excluded of course
so why why do you need the originalism
institute because originalism
is a
plausible
decent
substantive
way to interpret the constitution
because there's something good about it
because there's something edifying in
teaching students about originalism
it's not it's not the reason for it is
not academic freedom or freedom of
speech it's because it's good
it's a good thing to to
learn i i went back
i found this going around twitter
i'm so i'm i mean to give credit to
whoever posted it but it was matthew
schmitz
at first things
whoever i'll give i'll give him credit
even if even if you didn't post it came
back
and and found an earlier
uh president of georgetown university in
1950
writing about academic freedom we were
told these are the good old days of
academic freedom right
except he makes fun of it he calls it
the sacred fetish of academic freedom
he says if the united states he says in
the educational world today we are
witnessing
the foolhardy attempt either to bring
into being or to understand a thing
which has neither form nor matter
is subject to no standard or norm
is it neither limitation nor definition
the sacred fetish of academic freedom
this is the soft underbelly of our
american way of life and the sooner it
is armor-plated by some sensible
limitation the sooner will the future of
this nation be secured from fatal
consequences
two test questions
which imply limitation come to mind at
once when the matter of academic freedom
is discussed the first is the matter
being taught true or false and the
second if it is false and presented as
such may one prudently suppose that a
good and not evil end will eventuate
from its exposition
the true and the good this is that write
this one down highlight this one
the true and the good then are the
natural limitations of freedom
this is not an area for opinion because
opinion does not delineate for by its
very nature it packages the false with
the true
nor is this a matter for experimentation
because the prudent man does not
experiment with suicide suicide that
we're seeing academic suicide happening
on our campuses we're seeing national
suicide happening in washington d.c
the president of georgetown we should
take note because the georgetown is no
longer sending us their best okay older
presidents of georgetown had a much more
correct if the united states is to
continue in the western tradition which
made it great it behooves those of our
citizens interested in the present and
future of this nation to search out and
support the educational institutions
which are still striving to maintain
that tradition a tradition which was
grounded on freedom limited by a belief
in god by faith in the omnipotence of
truth and the beneficence of justice in
a word a tradition that freedom springs
from truth
but the truth is rarely freedom's
offspring
if our educational systems are going to
make any sense
they're just a microcosm of the country
you can really expand it out if our
country is going to make any sense
then and we're we know we're going to
have limitations on our freedom there
are always limitations on freedom
because this is a limited world
are we going to have the leftist
limitations
which are anything that's good interim
beautiful you got to get rid of and
anything that's filthy and perverted and
false and ugly you're going to exalt
or are we going to have these
limitations limitations belief in god
as our founding fathers believed as john
locke believed as john milton as all
these great
thinkers of of the era in which our
country was founded
limited by truth that there is such a
thing as truth and we can know it i bet
these georgetown law students don't
necessarily agree with that that there
is such a thing as justice are we going
to have a country
limited by truth justice and the
american way to quote superman
or are we going to have the opposite
i for one would like that good old i
want the superman country
i want the truth justice in the american
white country whatever we got now people
don't really like it you can you can
tell it by the polls so let's go back in
the other direction and that's going to
involve
telling the students who are crying and
rending their garments to keep their
mouths shut to go listen to heaven for
fend educate themselves so that we are
all capable of freedom i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles shall
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
today on the ben shapiro show whoopi
goldberg gets suspended from the view
for two weeks a new study from johns
hopkins finds that lockdown's had no
impact on coca-19 deaths and the u.s
national debt it's 30 trillion dollars
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen